Now, you may be wondering what can we learn from rolling balls down the hill.
I mean we all know what it looks like when a ball rolls down the hill right? Well, let's see.
This quiz is designed to just test your intuition, and I confessed I would not have passed this test
before I actually learned how to mathematically quantify motion.
So, let's say we have a ball, and we released it,
and at the same instant that we released it we start the timer.
So, the timer begins at zero seconds and we release it at this position here.
So, after 1 second, it's rolled this far.
So, given that we now have a ball that's released from rest here and after 1 second is here
so I want to know where will the ball be at t = 2 seconds.
It's gone from here to here in 1 second.
After 2 seconds, do you think it will be here or here or maybe it will be all the way over here.
Make your guess by selecting the appropriate button.